la centrale nucléaire et ses mystères
tout ce que vous avez toujours voulu
savoir sur son fonctionnement est ici
vraiment ça l'intérêt du centre
d'information du public c'est déjà de
faire venir les gens au plus près de la
centrale nucléaire de saint laurent des
eaux comprendre son fonctionnement
et puis après et de leur faire découvrir
la centrale sous un autre angle
apprendre en s'amusant déjà plus de 4000
personnes sont passées en 2019
certains se sont même essayés un escrime
game lancé depuis peu alors je souhaite
la bienvenue dans le laboratoire des
pionniers de nombreuses médailles des
sciences sont dispersés dans cette
étrange laboratoire mais attention la
plupart sont des leurres vous avez une
heure pour trouver celle qui vous
ouvriront le chemin de la connaissance
ses cinq médailles réunis vous
permettront d'ouvrir ce cryptex qui
contient rien de moins que la clé de
l'énergie du futur l'aventuré lancée le
maître du jeu est aussi son concepteur
qu'en pensez vous des recherches sur
internet et quelques heures de travail
ont été nécessaires pour tout mettre en
place
nez rouge vous ne vous laissez pas
tromper par les couleurs alors j'ai
commencé par par choisir un univers moi
j'ai un
bouh particulier pour l'histoire des
sciences donc j'ai voulu rendre hommage
à quelques-unes des grandes figures des
sciences
à partir de cela il a créé un scénario
et des énigmes de toutes sortes mais je
n'ai plus là là là ils sont trop bons et
donc le besoin d'être maintenant on
fouille on calcule on manipule bref on
cherche et on trouve si vous parvenez à
l'ouvré en moins d'une minute vous
battez le record quand ma mère m'a parlé
d'un escape game gratuit je me suis
demandé si j'allais être ça allait être
assez poussées etc et j'ai été agrément
agréablement surpris de la mise en scène
et des ennemis qui peuvent avoir été
intéressant moi qui connais pas trop le
système de l'électricité j'ai géré visé
le site un système mais bon j'ai pas le
droit d'en parler puisque c'est top
secret 37 minutes
record battu carroll a bien fait de
proposer cette sortie à léana thomas et
lionel rendez vous aux prochaines
vacances scolaires pour faire mieux